some breaking news from the UK travel
into the country is said to be affected
by a worker strike over the busy
Christmas period the Border Force at
several major airports including
Heathrow and Gatwick will walk off the
job from December 23rd let's bring it
out to Zero's Paul Brennan who joins us
live from London this is really going to
upset a lot of travel plans isn't it
it's certainly going to jeopardize the
getaway plans for well hundreds
hundreds of people because of the width
and breadth of the strike action that
the PCS Union are planning these are
border Force workers they're employed by
the home office they're public sector
workers working at airports and the
dates that we're talking about are
essentially the peak times that people
will be wanting to either get away for a
bit of winter sun or perhaps return home
to their home countries to see their
families after having spent time working
here in the UK the data from the
December 23rd all the way through to New
Year's Eve we're talking about hundreds
of thousands of people who are going to
be affected border Force basically
saying that they've met with the
government but they're rejecting a two
percent pay rise that the government had
offered Mark sawodka the union boss
saying um they keep saying the door is
open but there's a very strange door
because there's nothing behind it
um it's simply the government offer not
enough for the Union in response the
Heathrow Airport spoke said we're
working closely with Airlines to try to
mitigate the impact passengers are
advised to check their flight status
with their Airline but we're talking
about Gatwick Heathrow which is the UK's
busiest airport Manchester Birmingham
and Cardiff airports all of them
impacted over this critical Christmas
period and this isn't the the only
industrial action that's taking place
over the busy Christmas period is it
now what we really are in an Autumn of
uh discontent heading into a winter of
discontent to use that well-known phrase
what we essentially have is many many
years of a stagnant wage increases uh
increases in low single figures
um at the same time as inflation has in
the past year rocketed we're talking
about grocery inflation currently
running at around 14 so the prices are
going up by 14 year on Year we're
talking about uh CPI Consumer Price
inflation running at 11 and wages wage
increases running far below that
um such such as that people who are even
in employment are struggling to make
ends meet never mind those people who
are unemployed now the government is
struggling to meet the pay demands of
public sector workers but even private
sector workers are also complaining and
there have been a wave of strike actions
across many different areas of of the
economy nurses will go out on strike for
the first time ever next week we're
talking about ambulance staff as well
we're talking about baggage handlers at
airports rail workers have also been out
on strike for most of this year
intermittently
um there is a cost of living crisis here
in the UK that is really putting the
squeeze on on hard-working people and
they're simply not happy to they're not
prepared to put up with it anymore Al
jazeer of Paul Brennan reporting live
from London Paul many thanks indeed